So one of the big differences that comes
from direct manipulation screens, that
is things you touch to provide input
versus what we have in the desktop and
laptop world, is that the human body
all the sudden really starts to matter.
Before when we're building software for
desk tops and
laptops the size of our hands,
the size of our finger what's
a comfortable reach, that burden is
taken on by the keyboards and the mice.
Right so
long as the mouse is comfortable and
the keyboards comfortable the software
designer doesn't have to worry about it.
They don't have to think about
these are going to considerations.
As soon as software is something
that people can touch and
feel, the screen has to be considered
in the context of your hand.
How far can you reach that thumb?
How big is that thumb?
These things impact
where you put controls,
how large you make controls and how
easily those controls are to manipulate.
Anyone who's struggled
with a desktop form on
a mobile device knows these teeny little
tick boxes and radio buttons can be
super frustrating especially if
you're trying to pick a specific one.
So at the very least we need to consider
how to size controls, how to space them.
And that's sort of the bare minimum.
If you want to do one better then
you start thinking about well.
Is it possible to create this flow or
to complete this flow using what
I call one thumb one eyeball.
And one thumb one eyeball actually
illustrate this here since
I have a phone like all of you too.
In your pocket, kind of hold it like
this, and you look at it like this.
TV may be on, you may be outside,
or something like this.
How can I get something done,
just with these sorts of actions?
And that goes much broader
than just size, right?
It's where you place the controls,
it's what the flow looks like,
it's the kind of controls
you use as well.
And we have a lot of controls that
require the precision of a mouse cursor
to use well little like spinner wheels
that you find on the desktop drop
down menus that you find desktop.
All those controls need to be
rethought for touch screens so
that they can actually
be used by our hands.